You appreciate their friendship and you want them to know it.
Pick a gift for your best friend that conveys how much you cherish them.
Put together a specialized basket of your best friend's favorite items.
An avid reader might like a first edition book by a favorite author,...
...and maybe designer bookmarks along with treats that they can enjoy while reading.
Treat her to a day of pampering at a spa,...
...with your heartfelt encouragement that she relax and enjoy herself.
Choose her birthstone as a gift,...
...or choose a piece of costume jewelry from a boutique you know she frequents.
Pick out clothes only if you know her size and taste well,...
...or else the gift may be taken as commentary on her fashion sense.
Create a friendship collage or shadow box with photos and mementos...
...that commemorate the fun times you've had together.
Add her favorite tea or gourmet coffees.
She'll be sure to love it!